and we're gonna be watching the markets
today after the president's topic night
economic adviser announced his
resignation Gary Cohen is one of the
more than 20 White House officials who
have resigned been fired or reassigned
under President Trump he disagreed with
the president's planned tariffs on steel
and aluminum imports Dow futures point
to a big drop in stocks at the markets
opening
Jericka Duncan is at the White House
Jericho good morning good morning Gary
Cohen who had a rocky relationship with
the president is the latest high-profile
aide to leave this administration and as
you mentioned Kohn did not agree with
the president's plan to impose tariffs
on steel or aluminum imports well now
with his departure it may just clear the
way for the president's plan to move
forward they want a piece of the West
Wing
president Trump denied that morale and
his White House was low everybody wants
to work in the White House and claims he
could fill any vacant position
I'll have a choice of the ten top people
having to do with that position less
than two hours later he was looking for
a new chief economic adviser after Gary
cone resigned coincided with many
Republican leaders and arguing the
president's newly proposed tariffs on
metal imports could be a drag on the
economy
this could sort of metastasize into a
larger trade war during a meeting with
the prime minister of Sweden the
president seemed undeterred by the
concerns the trade war hurts them
doesn't hurt us in addition to concerns
about White House staffing the president
was also slapped with a civil lawsuit
Tuesday by adult film star stormy
Daniels Daniel's alleges that a quote
hush agreement she signed days before
Election Day in 2016 which forbid her
from disclosing details of her personal
relationship with mr. Trump is not
binding because mr. Trump himself never
signed it the lawsuit says mr. Trump
used the alias David Dennison for the
non-disclosure agreement and that a
consultant firm was created to process
the payments to Daniel's as a way to
further insulate mr. Trump from later
scrutiny Daniel's also alleges mr. Trump
purposely avoided signing the agreement
himself so he could later diss
any knowledge of the non-disclosure
agreement president Trump's lawyer
Michael Cohen admitted to paying
$130,000 to Daniel's before Election Day
of 2016 Daniel says she was given the
payment to prevent her from coming
forward with allegations against the
president Cohen has denied involvement
from the Trump Organization and Trump
campaign Noora Noora Trika thank you